hey everybody and welcome to my first
planet sube the franchise mode habitat
speed build
I swear that's the most concise way that
I find to say what I'm doing here I know
in the past couple of days I haven't
uploaded as many videos as some
youtubers have been doing of this
particular game one of those youtubers
even asked me why I'm not doing so and
if I'm really feeling the game at all
and I have to be honest all I need to do
is look at my steam page and I can
already see that planet zoo has
destroyed my social life and my
university obligations completely but
honestly all this time I've been playing
the game mostly
alone and haven't recorded anything just
because well me being me I think my
youtube channel is nothing if not based
on my personal passions and interests
and expertise on certain things hence
why it started out very much about
rollercoasters and cities because these
are my two major hobbies and the thing
that I study basically but in the case
of this zoos I wasn't sure if I was
really well equipped to make the usual
kind of videos about it and also I have
to say I wasn't even sure if I was gonna
make videos of Planet two at all before
the beta because to be honest I really
only want to make videos of something if
I really really enjoy it and if it's
actually a passion of mine
I think France here tried to get me to
make Jurassic world evolution videos but
mmm that's just not happening
so honestly I wasn't really sure if I
was gonna go there anyway but after
playing the franchise mode on my own for
a while I realized that I was completely
hooked and I couldn't stop playing it so
I figured might as well make some videos
eventually when I get around to it and
when I can feel like I've got enough
practice I've done enough research and
I've got enough overall expertise in the
game to try and make some slightly
informative videos about it and
hopefully we're at this point because I
finally had an idea for an enclosure
that I think it worked for a first video
which is a tiger trail very much
inspired by the San Diego Zoo blends
which I found online which look really
cool I've never actually been to the San
Diego Zoo but it looks absolutely
amazing and
love to go there one day but yeah it was
very much inspired by that although this
is slightly different because instead of
Sumatran Tiger's I'll be going for
Bengal tigers here and instead of the
tropical foliage biome that San Diego
has I'm gonna go for the traditional
Himalayan landscape of Bhutan which is a
bit of an odd choice considering that
most of the Bengal tigers to live in
India and there are approximately only
about a hundred and three tigers
estimated to be in Bhutan at the moment
but it's it's a kind of architecture and
landscape that I'm really fascinated by
and actually the country in general I
think is really fascinating so it's
something that I wanted to give it try
it's also something that I never saw
anybody do before although right after I
had the idea and I've posted it on this
quote somewhere somebody else posted a
really beautiful Bhutanese enclosure on
a different discord which was definitely
having the same idea at the same time I
suppose but yeah it's something that you
don't see too much because Bhutan is
really just a small country on the
border between China and India in the
Himalayan region and it has less than a
million inhabitants but it's a very
traditional country that really holds on
to its traditions of especially
architecture and aesthetics which i
think is really inspiring and there are
some Himalayan Tigers in the temperate
forests of these mountain regions so I
thought it would be a really interesting
way to build an enclosure like that now
as for the overall design that I'm going
for here which as you can see is a bit
complicated and not very straight to the
point here I wanted to combine as much
as possible the nature and culture of
the region that these Tigers are from so
I'm trying to combine the the rock work
and foliage of the area with the
architecture in some ways which you'll
see in a minute but for the interaction
that the animals will have with the
guests I really wanted to give the
guests as many different types of
unobstructed views of the Tigers as
possible so hence while you can see the
the past kind of sneaking around an
everything I know it might not make too
much sense at the moment but you've got
a view from a bridge I've got a view
from a lo perspective there will be a
central building in the middle here
where there will be educational items
and things like that where you can have
a whole different view of the enclosures
and finally on the very lowest floor
there just underneath the water level
you'll have a slightly underwater view
of the tiger so in case they go swimming
you can actually have a completely
different perspective there so that's
really a large part of the idea for the
overall design of this exhibit and then
of course it was inspired by the idea of
a tiger trail so it's not just a simple
enclosure that kind of shows off a
habitat for the animals but I wanted to
make it feel as much as possible like
you actually go into the area this is
this general space is really the tigers
own space and the guests are well guests
in this area but you know you're kind of
making your way through this general
biome instead of just looking at it from
a distance which I thought would be much
more interesting and immersive so you
really surround the guests with the
Tigers and I'm trying to also for that
camouflage the barriers as much as
possible trying to make them look not
too obvious so I'm using a lot of rock
work and things like that to keep the
Tigers away from the guests and vice
versa which is also a bit of an
experiment I'm really hoping that all of
these rocks will be inescapable for the
Tigers or at least unclaimed herbal so
I'm trying to not just make it look nice
and natural but they really also have to
be very safe of course that's part of
the challenge as well but yeah I really
want to make it seem like you're making
your way through a natural biome as
opposed to a completely fenced off and
enclosed habitats and then of course
well in my case of course there are some
ethical considerations as well in it I
know that this is just the game but I
kind of like to take things to the next
level I suppose and personally in real
life I really only enjoy zoos if it's
very clear that they care for the enemy
and if the habitats are in order if
they're large enough and well-maintained
etc which just makes me feel less bad to
visit what is essentially an animal
prison so there are a bunch of things
that I wanted to keep in mind regarding
that for this habitat as well
we've got Tigers which like the swim so
of course there's some water I wanted to
have enough foliage to at least somewhat
imitates these mountain region forests
that they're from and of course a lot of
rock work as well because I can't well I
can't really work much with the ground
textures those are all set in stone and
we're in an Asian grassland so that
doesn't really fit so I really have to
use the rock work that try and sell the
idea of the Himalayan mountain region
then I also wanted to make the enclosure
quite large I wanted to give the Tigers
enough room to roam in a lot of sue's
pacing for wild cats as an issue where
they just pace around the parameters of
their enclosure and especially if the
enclosures are too small this can be
really depressing sites so I want the
enclosure also to give enough space for
the Tigers to run around and explore and
pace through their territory without
endlessly going back and forth which
there's a funny Dutch word for but I've
no idea what exactly the English word
for it is I guess pacing works but in
Dutch we call an ice barren which is
like polar bearing anyway yeah that's
something that I wanted to keep in mind
so that kind of comes back in the shape
of the habitats since its kind of shaped
as a crescents so it's not entirely
around the paths there's really only one
area where they go underneath the paths
and where they can actually cross into
the other space but because of that it's
a very lengthy habitats that kind of
wraps its way around the paths and
around this building in the middle and
finally animals first and guest views
second I think you always want to give
some spaces for the animals to hide from
the guests so there are definitely some
blind spots here and there and some
dense patches of foliage where the
Tigers will be able to rest as well
now I'm falling behind my time lapse
here at this point I started to build
the building in the middle of the
habitats which is really the hub of this
whole area and I guess you could almost
call it a weenie although I really don't
want to use that term that's a very
theme Parkash thing and I definitely
don't want to try building weenies in
the zoo but in this case it's really
primarily an area like a central viewing
platform for guests to have an overview
of the entire enclosure while also
providing some shade and some shelter
from the natural elements and also it's
a good place to put the educational
stuff some of the screens and things
like that just a general area for you
know a center points where people could
congregate and get together and be the
main place to view the the animals from
because given the fact that the paths
kind of wind through the habitat I
really wanted to find one anchor points
where people could you know primarily
stay and also I think it's a it's a good
way to connect the the architectural
cultural elements a bit to the the
natural parts of the habitats since I
was trying to make this look like a
Bhutanese farmhouse and Bhutan is very
conservative in regards to architectural
traditions and even until recently there
were very strict rules in place about
how buildings should look in regards to
traditional architecture and what's
interesting is that the Ministry of
Works and human settlement of Bhutan has
laid out a guide which you can get
online in a PDF form for free with all
of the details about Bhutanese
architecture and there's a lot of really
interesting facts in that I think the
core principle that kind of demarcated
as well as many other forms of Asian
architecture is really that it's trying
to adapt to nature a lot of Western
architectural styles really kind of
smashed nature down and try to establish
some kind of geometric or symmetrical
building style but in this case it's
much more adapting to nature
so you find a lot of natural materials
it's famous for not using any plans so
famously some Bhutanese quote-unquote
architects would have used no drawings
and no measurements to create their
buildings although I have to be very
honest I'm not entirely clear about
sourcing this because even the the
ministry's own page has said that this
is more of a general myth than it is
really a totally confirmed thing and
obviously judging by the buildings that
are in Bhutan nowadays a lot of them
have been planned and there are plans
available for all of the most famous
Bhutanese buildings in that PDF as well
I should actually link that down in
description just for those who are
interested in it but yeah that's also
another thing and just like another
other different Asian architectural
styles they don't use any nails
everything is done using joints etc so
that's really interesting although not
really something that really matters to
I'm building here what I'm building here
is a really a traditional farmhouse
which I'm not sure how to pronounce I'm
not gonna try and say the word but yeah
it's it's generally an elevated house
with a small footprint and a very wide
roof to protect against all kinds of
weather elements what's also really
interesting is that the Attic is usually
kept open because it's used to store
food which needs to stay dry and airy so
you find that even though the entire
buildings are enclosed you'll often have
an open space with all of the timber
work pretty much exposed underneath
these large overhanging white flat roofs
and well I have to say I'm also
following more the overall shape and
ideas of Bhutanese architecture rather
than the full detailing because
obviously we don't have a Bhutanese set
so I'm mostly just using a combination
of different limestone pieces and wood
to create the timber work look of
Bhutanese buildings and then a bunch of
Indian pieces to create the detailing
and windows and things like that so the
detailing isn't exactly the same but I'm
following the overall idea so you can
see here with this building these very
wide overhanging roofs with the exposed
work another thing that comes back in
Bhutanese architecture is as you go up
inside these traditional houses the
windows get bigger so you'll find the
biggest windows and decorations on the
top floor of these buildings actually
and on the bottom floors there are often
religious white walls with some small
windows but it's much more simple so in
this case I tried following the same
general idea here even though I do have
those large openings on the bottom floor
because that's that is where the paths
are and that is where I wanted to have
an observation view of the habitats so
of course it's not exactly the same but
I think it's you know it taking
inspiration enough to a point where you
get a very similar-looking
environment and the extra decoration on
top which is experimenting with for a
while there it's also not entirely
accurate you would more often find that
kind of thing on Bhutanese temples or
castle kind of architecture but I
thought it looked good honestly so
that's really just why I added that one
really really cool Bhutanese building
that I think a lot of people will
recognize or if you haven't seen it
before you definitely should check it
out it's called the Tiger's Nest well I
don't think officially so but it's a
monastery on the cliff side of a
mountain and it's absolutely beautiful
it's really cool there are probably some
pictures of it on reddit that go viral
every month or so but yeah it's really
cool to see just how it's integrated
into the natural environments and how
you see all of these ideas coming back
in this building it's just generally a
building then I recommend looking up and
just falling over how cool it looks now
at this point the observation building
is finished so I went ahead and put in
the rest of the actual habitats and
started working on the rook work and
foliage and things like that you might
notice then I didn't record everything I
did I did cut some parts out of this
time that stores a lot of just moving
around and tinkering about with certain
things I added the rock wall at the back
the habitats here which looks much nicer
I think than just a wooden fence I did
add a wooden fence here and there
because realistically I don't think as
you would be able to afford a rock wall
around an entire habitat as large as
this one but wherever I could and
especially where it was very much in
view I wanted to make the barrier a rock
work facade as well to try and make
everything look a bit more realistic and
immersive and I'm just tailing the paths
here a little bit although I have to say
I'm really not focusing on the paths
that much I'll be keeping those mostly
as they are I think if I had more time
or if this habitat was smaller I would
have really just detailed everything and
did everything myself but can be really
time-consuming to do that and we only
have so much time in the beta know this
is still a beta in the end so I wanted
to keep that for another day maybe in
some future zoos our experiments more
with that for now I really wanted to
keep the the focus for the rest of the
video on trying to build the habitat
itself and trying to make it look as
natural as possible while also keeping
the Tigers inside the habitat and
keeping all of the humans outside the
habitat preferably as well
although I'm very glad we don't have to
worry about little kids jumping into
habitats as far as I'm aware I do want
to make it look safe enough just for
realism purposes so there's that as well
oh and at this point I suppose I did
start to detail the building a little
bit more because it was looking a little
bit empty and undecorated and I found
some inspiration just from hanging a
bunch of different fabrics outside give
it some color some more detail it's bit
over the top and a bit kitschy I think
but at the same time I think it just
makes it look much more inviting and
charming so I just went ahead and ended
that stuff in there Bhutan isn't quite
India of course but it's close so I
think some of the Indian scenery pieces
can definitely help at least giving the
idea of
boutonnieres detailing and on the inside
I put a bunch of props I'm not the
biggest fan of props in zoos but given
that this building is trying to pretend
being a traditional building and trying
to set the setting of an actual
Bhutanese area I think it's fitting to
at least add some props and make it feel
a tiny bit lived in to just help with
the general immersiveness of the area
and that is basically it for all that at
this point I started working on another
shelter I do already have one shelter
made out of rocks on the other side of
the habitat so that should be fine but I
didn't want to have one main shelter
next to the gates where employees will
get in and deliver the food and all that
so I'm building a very simple shelter
here very generally inspired by the roof
shape of Bhutanese buildings but it's
not really specifically based on
anything this is all quite simple and it
won't be that visible from a guests
perspective there will definitely be
some trees and things like that to hide
the view a little bit but this will be
the main and the largest shelter for the
Tigers I was also considering building
an actual indoor section where Tigers
can go to I haven't worked on that in
this video and I think it shouldn't be
too much of an issue given that the
climates of this region is at least
acceptable for the Tigers but if I ever
decide to add some sort of indoor
section where guests can look at the
Tigers indoors I can always attach it to
this building or on the other side of
the habitats I don't know it's it's a
possibility but in this case I didn't go
quite all the way there and honestly I
was happy with how the habitats is so
far anyway so yeah there's that also I
added a waterfall here which you didn't
see me do on video because I cut that
section out as well but I needed to add
that I noticed that pretty much every
youtuber who is ending a waterfall in an
enclosure so I was like who am i if I
don't add a waterfall to this enclosure
so decided to get that element out there
you know you need to do it at some point
anyway so might as well do it
but now honestly I thought it looks
really good in this position and I
thought it would also look nice from a
gas perspective if you're looking from
the house of course I'm trying to still
keep in mind the different sight lines
that guests will see when they're
looking into the habitat so that was
definitely part of that decision as well
and finally I'm adding some important
buildings in the back here but yeah that
is basically it for this build so I'm
gonna leave you guys with some clips of
habitat and you can see the Tigers
enjoying it here I only have two Tigers
so not too much the film but as far as
I've been able to tell I've tested them
for quite a while they are not able to
escape thankfully and scare off any
guests so that is nice
they've been enjoying the outside and
really running around quite a lot and
they seem to be fine in fact even the
terrain coverage and the foliage was
perfectly fine I didn't even have to
fine-tune that which was a total luck
because I really wasn't sure if this
terrain was gonna be suitable but yeah
I'm very glad that it is I didn't really
have to think ER with anything anymore
after putting the Tigers in I just added
some habitat things enrichment items and
things like that of course so yeah I'm
very happy with this habitat and I hope
you guys liked watching me build it and
if I have enough time between my
university obligations which I will
actually attend to to some degree I
would like to build some other habitats
but regardless I'll try and do some
other stuff in the planet to beta as
well so keep your eyes out for some
future videos anyway that's been it
thank you guys for watching and I hope
to see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]